what's up buddy
hey can you hear me yeah so it says
you're married with an infant son
wondering if divorce is the right path
yeah yeah so love the content uh great
to be on the show
i i learned to uh
too late i didn't court long enough and
i was just i'm sorry how old are you
i'm 28. so you're 28 and how old your
kid
uh he's about a month old now
okay and are you still with the mom i am
i am and that's the question i've been
thinking a lot about this over we've
been married now a year and a half i've
been thinking a lot about this lately
um since we got married actually you
know she's
really great and it's one of those
things where she's so awesome and she's
always tries to be there she's very
supportive she's a great asset to my
life
but my life is is a bit of a mess and
i've been just starting to try and put
it together
and and what i realized is that i need
a somebody who can challenge me and i
need like a
a partner like an equal partner does
that make sense okay
hold on a second because now you're
talking now you're talking feminism
okay okay there's no there's no equal
partnerships
in men and women's relationships if you
follow the red pill
they're very different so let me just
stop you right there so
you said she's wonderful she supports
you blah blah blah so why do you want to
untie the knot well two primary reasons
the first is that it's really difficult
just to have an intelligent conversation
with her
she's well-meaning but it i feel like
i'm married down when it
comes to intelligence it's okay it's
like and it's
i've like i've tried i really have but
okay so
you want a chick that's going to
challenge you
yeah well at least help me see things
that i don't see like i feel like i'm
the smartest person in the room
all the time okay well you're probably
going to feel that way with women
pretty much for the rest of your life oh
geez i hope not yeah
and that's and that's totally fine dude
i don't
whenever i hear guys that start talking
about stuff like you know i just want an
equal partner and i just want somebody
that challenges me sort of thing
that's feminist [ __ ] that's that's
what they've been cramming down our
throats for like
decades um you know i can go back in the
memory banks and it's like
you know the huxtables you know the
cosby show equal partnership they're
both doctors
except for who gets treated like [ __ ] in
that tv show bill cosby
that's always the man yeah right he's
always a bumbling idiot right
so whenever i think like you know equal
partnership and you know i want somebody
like do you really want to come home
after chasing excellence all day putting
your dent in the universe
doing big [ __ ] to have some [ __ ]
[ __ ] in your house like
lecture you about something not going
the right way maybe you put the
you know your dark shoes or sorry your
dark socks and the white hamper
right yeah i'm more likely to actually
tell her to do that actually okay
and she is but me but i mean like what's
wrong exactly with this marriage like
are you not attracted to this woman
yeah so there's also that there's like
i'm physically it's
she's she's also not entirely there
either like she's cute and all but
but it's either it's both the physical
attraction that's kind of
eh and then it's also the intelligence
because i'm not looking for
to contend with anybody so let me
clarify that i'm not going to contend
i'm looking for somebody who will help
me problem solve you have a problem that
i'm not
no no women don't solve men's problems
men solve men's problems if you need a
board of advisors like if you need
um you know to run something up the
flagpole to see if everybody's going to
salute it sort of thing
then do that with your you know with
your boys like do you have brothers you
have close friends
i have i have a brother i've been pretty
loner though for a long time
all right well don't rely on women to
help you solve problems
because you're not going to be solving
your problems you're going to be solving
her problems
whatever the solution is it's going to
be presented will solve her needs
not yours yeah
interesting men men solve problems for
everybody
women solve problems for themselves have
you read my book
no i actually read this you must read my
book yes i read the sample earlier today
and i saw on kindle that it has that you
narrated it right yeah well yeah on the
audible version but
what i was going to say is that they
tell men and women very very different
things when it comes to
making choices and they tell men do
what's right
but they tell women you do what's right
for you girl
okay you don't need her to help you
solve problems you need to learn how to
solve your own problems and be confident
in the problems that you need to solve
this isn't a marriage problem this is a
you problem jay
yeah and so you're
you're expecting your wife to do
everything that the feminist narrative
has told you
that you should expect her to do and
like the child's small i'm assuming that
she's taking care of the child while
you're working right
yeah yeah so you bring home the bacon
and let her cook it up make sure she
cooks it up nice and [ __ ] tasty
right and as far as the attraction
things goes okay look you know
women throw on some weight when they get
pregnant but hey
it's not acceptable to carry that [ __ ]
around for the rest of your life let's
fix that
right you figure out how it is it you
want to communicate that but
your but your best way to deliver that
is
is for you to lead the example by being
the giga chad
you know yeah how tall are you i'm about
five seven
what do you weigh like 190. okay so you
got a little bit of weight to lose
right that's right that's right yeah so
you know lead the household
and show her what strong masculine
virtues look like
good advice it's good advice i'm not
saying that you need to stay married to
her i'm not saying that you need to
leave her but
what i'm saying is what i'm hearing here
is there's a lot of [ __ ] that you got to
work on for yourself because if you
leave this marriage
you're going to run into a similar set
of problems with another check and guess
what
you're going to be a single dad with a
small child in tow is it a boy or a girl
what's a boy okay you're gonna be a
single dad with a small
you know child in toe you're not exactly
high on the totem pole
of you know the dating marketplace as a
guy with a small child
you know the thing that i always found
you know funny about women is women
women can have three kids from three
different fathers
and still not want to date a single dad
with one kid
so i would start working on the you
issues
right yeah and if you want to talk a
little bit more in the future call
you know call back in a future show but
read my book you know read some more of
my recommended work
okay work on yourself because i mean
even if you are going to
leave the marriage you're going to want
to hit the ground running you're going
to want to prepare for the divorce
because
it's not exactly friendly to fathers
either right yeah yeah so so
to summarize so i understand don't even
think about leaving the marriage yet
just focus on the things that i can
control like that i need to fix right
now
hitting the gym starting to chase
excellence
you came across my channel by the way um
you know i saw one of your videos like
long time ago
the video about what like what women to
avoid or like the test of the test to
the test i did i dated girls and i did
the key test because i had a
an old isuzu that it still worked on
right most of them failed miserably
but the last couple of days i i think i
saw
uh i think i saw something pop up and i
clicked it and i've just been consuming
a lot of your stuff
okay and and i just i i i know i need to
fix a lot of things in my life already
but
i can tell from your starting point that
that you're approaching
your your life your relationships
um and the expectations that you have
with women
are broken and my
basically talks about that like my book
itself deals with
broken belief systems and lies we've
been told
as men that we've subscribed to that we
take hook line and sinker and i was one
of them you know
i you know i get a t-shirt that says hey
you know i was that guy but um
yeah like you've got to unplug from a
lot of those lies and you know
that's basically the reason why i titled
the book the unplugged alpha because
you're unplugging from all those
[ __ ] lies
right and that will help you level up
start there and then
you know call back in i do the show
every monday 8pm eastern standards so
call back in whenever you want we'll
talk again in the future but start with
that
sounds good i appreciate it rich take
care all right jay see you man
you